.
MITTELSTADT HAS IT IN THE
CORNER.
UP HIGH FOR DAHLIN.
OVER TO THOMPSON SCORES!
TAGE THOMPSON WITH A ROCKET AND
IT'S A POWER PLAY GOAL TO MAKE
IT 5-1 BUFFALO.
>> Greg: THIS THOMPSON KID IS
A STAR IN THE MAKING.
HE IS REALLY A SPECIAL PLAYER.
AND WHAT A SHOT THIS IS HERE.
AND THE BUFFALO SABRES, YOU
KNOW, THEY WILL SNEAK UP ON A
LOT OF TEAMS THIS YEAR.
THE YOUNG PLAYERS WILL COME ON
THEIR OWN AND FIST ROUND PICKS.
HOW ABOUT THIS SHOT?
THOMPSON LETS IT RIP.
A BEAUTIFUL HOLE HERE BY DAHLIN
THAT VLADAR HAD TO WAIT FOR AS
DID THE DEFENCE.
THAT LEFT THOMPSON WIDE OPEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE RINK AND
HE JUST BLASTS IT HOME FOR A 4-1
LEAD COMING UP HERE AND THEY'RE
GOING UP STAIRS.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHY.
>> John: MIGHT BE CHECKING IT
WENT IN.
CAME IN AND OUT SO QUICKLY.
>> Greg: LOOKED LIKE THIS.
AND SHOULD BE 5-1 LEAD.
ON THE HEAD SET FROM THE
SITUATION ROOM.
>> John: IS IT IN?
OFF THE CROSS BAR.
HIT THE CROSS BAR.
THAT HAD EVERY ONE FOOLED.
>> ON FURTHER VIDEO REVIEW THE
PUCK DID NOT CROSS THE LINE AND
HIT THE CROSS BAR.
NO GOAL.
FACE OFF INSIDE.
>> John: BREAK FOR THE FLAMES.
THE WAY THE PUCK CAME OUT AND
THE WAY EVERY ONE REACTED.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT THE WAY
EVERYBODY REACTED.
I THINK THE WHOLE -- LOOK AT
VLADAR.
GETS ENOUGH OF IT WIT THE
SHOULDER.